[Musique]
mon fils c'est un musicien
il a 15 ans il va avoir 16 ans demain en
fait mais il joue
tu sais euh de la basse et il joue du métal
mais il joue aussi dans écrit de la
musique hip-hop donc il aime le hip-hop
mais il aime aussi le métal là-bas  y a-t-il des
enfants qui ne le comprennent pas, il
y a des enfants qui sont comme oh
c'est de la musique de vieux
ou ils ne connaissent pas les vrais tambours ou les
vraies guitares ou comme
vous le savez mais presque toujours quand ils
entendent
une grande chanson de sabbat noir ou un  super
chanson de metallica
vous savez alors ils l'obtiennent ou s'ils la
voient s'ils la voient beaucoup la
voient en fait c'est comme oh wow ils
jouent vraiment de leurs instruments je veux dire que
cela peut effrayer certains jeunes parce que
vous les emmenez à  un concert de métal
et ils n'ont jamais connu ce genre
d'énergie
et il y a 60 000 personnes dans le stade
et ils sont tout ce que vous connaissez et vous devez vous
sentir spécial
vous voyez tous les différents types de personnes que
vous connaissez vieux jeunes
et ce n'est pas à propos  la politique ou tu sais
culturellement
c'est m  ixed donc c'est assez spécial
[Music]
parfois les cris
ce n'est pas vraiment je veux dire c'est juste une
question de goût certains
des cris que je ne comprends pas toujours
et certains d'entre eux que je comprends donc
ça devient un choix du le  auditeur
je suis allé dans une école de jazz
tu sais j'y suis allé j'ai étudié le jazz
[musique]
quand j'avais 19 ans et euh
et j'ai aussi grandi avec beaucoup de musique soul
flamenco et tout quand j'étais jeune
j'entendais tout ça
alors j'ai juste  comme la musique pour la musique et je
connais beaucoup de musiciens comme
même kirk notre guitariste il a
grandi en
écoutant beaucoup de musique soul et funky à
san francisco donc
ça dépend de l'individu tu ne peux
pas dire
oh ces gars  jouer du métal donc
ils n'écoutent que cette musique
[Musique]
dans certains groupes de métal, les paroles peuvent
parler de vous savez la sorcellerie et
satan et des trucs comme ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'avec comme le
sabbat noir que beaucoup de gens voulaient
croire était
le genre ultime  de bande satanique ils
ha  j'ai quelques paroles qui peuvent vous faire penser
que ça célèbre, ce n'est en fait pas
ça vous parle des maux
de la guerre, donc vous devez imaginer
certaines de ces paroles
plus comme un cinéma de
cinéma donc c'est cinématographique et ensuite vous
entendez la musique que
vous regardez le  couverture de l'album et vous vous faites en quelque
sorte peur,
donc ce n'est pas trop différent d'
aller voir un film d'horreur,
certaines personnes le perçoivent de la mauvaise façon,
vous savez, je suis sûr qu'il y a des groupes
mais pas beaucoup qui
célèbrent satan vous savez dans un  manière positive
[Musique]
les fans de métal sont des gens très positifs
aujourd'hui maintenant les fans de métal
vous savez que les fans moyens font du yoga
ils sont végétaliens la musique métal pour moi
a toujours été une sortie donc je pense que
c'est thérapeutique c'est comme une thérapie
tu sais que tu écoutes une bonne
chanson de métal et ça peut te faire te sentir vraiment
bien
te faire sentir heureux tu sais que ça peut être
inspirant
méta  llica mec
tu sais que ça marche pour metallica les
foules de metal sont incroyables
l'énergie est incroyable la puissance est
incroyable
et euh tu sais que c'est presque comme tribal
tu connais des guerriers et c'est le sentiment
que je pense que tu peux réellement ressentir
d'un métal
un heavy metal  concert donc je conseillerais aux
personnes qui n'ont jamais vu un
grand spectacle de metal d'aller y jeter un coup d'oeil
je pense qu'ils seront impressionnés